Donovan is an Oklahoman hey Donovan your
question for dr. D hi guys good hi Andy
oh man I'm more trended okay I'm working
you know working in New Mexico in the
old field and I'm actually a Salesman in
the old film and today I start going to
rigs and there's no sales calls allowed
due to the corona virus miss any other
that's the general state of the oil
field and my wife works as an as an RN
were a health department and I'm out in
New Mexico trying to get to the debt
snowball but my wife is is knee-deep up
into Corona and she's taking things a
little more seriously than I am until
this morning but I realize that now that
was a little serious and so I'm kind of
freaking out but I'm doctor you know I'm
on my way home from New Mexico trying to
figure out what the heck to you and how
to approach this how to be you know how
to say this but I mean fortunately I'm
not I'm not laid off I'm just I just
can't work out there so I'm gonna be
basically about half pay there you go
and so I just moved here from I just
just moved here from Lubbock Texas and
so I get the oilfield I get the ups and
downs I get the the roller coaster that
god Bless You Man wave to wave to him
there you go what I would tell you is
this you've got a couple of things that
you mentioned to me one is I'm scared
that I'm gonna have to go home and tell
my wife that I'm not bringing home as
much money as I am and I'm scared for
the woman that I love who's out there
serving this community in a scary messy
situation and I'm scared for her too and
so I think the greatest gift you can
give your wife right now is to sit down
at the kitchen table and hold her hand
and look her in the eye and say I'm
scared and I love you and we're gonna
get through this together and then
together you will make a plan for what
tomorrow's gonna look like and the next
day and that's going to include finances
that's going to include how you're going
to honor each other when you're both
scared nervous that's going to include
how you're going to help her with the
laundry when she's got a
she's rotating scrubs on and on and on
and on but it's about making a plan
making a plan together and being being
vulnerable with the woman that you love
this is a scary moment for you
financially it's a scary moment for your
wife health-wise and it's scary for
everybody around us and it's going to be
that calm collected a response and you
look in her nine-cent I love you I'm
with you in this and we're gonna get
through this together okay
have you guys been through Financial
Peace University yeah Dave we have and
I'm actually I mean we have been through
it yeah we've got the membership and the
whole deal and we'll go through it
together and order and we're all there
that snowball we paid off not $30,000
good for graduation so the good news is
that you guys know you have my point is
you've got the tools then not
necessarily debt-free but you know how
to handle the money and so you've got
the tools to sit down and say with a
reduced income for a short period of
time we're gonna do a budget we're gonna
lay out a game plan of it where every
dollar is going to go we're gonna do a
budget with our time we're gonna do a
budget with our energy on where it's all
going to go and what John was just
saying was brilliant and then you just
have a game plan and you share the
vulnerability and you share the game
plan and dude you guys can fight through
anything you're not the kind of people
that this is gonna take out you're gonna
be just fine in 60 days you're fine and
there's nothing that drives my wife
crazy ur the one I try to bow up and act
like nothing's bothering me because she
can feel it right she knows and so
there's something magic about sitting
down and saying I'm scared but I love
you yeah I mean and you don't have to do
that every 20 minutes you know watch you
make a plan right you know the one time
er the two times I mean is until you
just say what's really going on right
then yes you know just be out loud about
it and that's there's something make a
plan to follow the plan there's
something about putting the truth on the
table that calls in the spotlight that
causes the demons to run for the corner
doesn't it ever eats every time they
just they can't stand the light every
time just even if it's ugly truth it's
the truth that's right and fear just
dissipates and how many guys have you
talked to over the years that would call
you and say I realized I was going to be
half pay so I started borrowing money
and I got my Nam over my head
yeah and he's not gonna do that he's not
gonna do that no what she's working a
lot of hours she may make up the income
uh-huh and what a blessing she is to
these communities out there yeah
absolutely health care workers good for
her good for her